parish values but in three short years
we rebuilt our military we revived our
economy
we secured our border supported law
enforcement
and stood for life liberty and the
constitution of the united states of
america
and it all starts with our national
defense after years of reckless budget
cuts
when joe biden was vice president
and yesterday i just heard that leading
democrats in washington
are actually already promising massive
defense
cuts if they somehow regain
all of capitol hill in the white house
[Music]
but under president trump i'm proud to
report to you as your vice president
and as the proud father of a united
states marine
[Music]
and thanks to the strong support of our
allies in congress
we're finally giving our soldiers
sailors airmen marines
and coast guard the resources and the
support they need to defend this nation
[Applause]
president donald trump has actually
signed the largest increase in our
national defense since the days of
ronald reagan
and he actually also made sure that we
would continue to be as
dominant in space as we are on land and
sea and
air when he founded the united states
space force
[Music]
so it's about standing with those who
serve but also standing with all of you
who did serve in the uniform
you know when joe biden was vice
president america saw years of scandal
that shocked the conscience of the
nation at the va you remember
i mean we literally had veterans that
were dying
on waiting lists waiting to get care at
va hospitals
but when president trump stepped into
the oval office
all that changed we signed the most
sweeping reforms of the va
in 50 years we fired more than 3
thousand
va employees that were not giving our
veterans the care that they earned
and veterans choice is now available for
every veteran
in america
and that's one more reason why we need
a combat veteran on the armed services
committee
in a republican majority we need six
more years
of senator joni ernst in the united
states senate
it's been an incredible champion of our
national defense and our veterans and
senator we're grateful
and on the economy in our first three
years
after joe biden had tried to tax and
spend and bail us back to a growing
economy
and presided over the slowest recovery
in more than 80 years
president donald trump created the
greatest economy
in american history and we're doing it
again
[Music]
you might have heard about it with
today's new gdp
numbers just this morning the american
economy grew by more than 33 percent
in the third quarter shattering any
previous american record the great
american comeback is
on
and with four more years of president
donald trump in the white house we're
going to bring the american economy back
bigger than ever before
you know the president said today
the third quarter gdp was quote the
biggest and best in the history of the
country and it was
he actually said in his own words not
even close
he also said that next year will be
fantastic with four more years
of president donald trump in the white
house
you know this great american comeback is
a testament
it's a testament to the character and
the resilience and the strength of the
american people
and it's a tribute to a president and to
our allies in the congress
who advanced the policies that created
the greatest economy the world's ever
known
it's amazing to think now in the midst
of a global pandemic
joe biden actually wants to raise taxes
by four trillion dollars and he wants to
pass his own
version a two trillion dollar version of
the green new deal
under president donald trump we cut
taxes across the board for working
families and small businesses
we rolled back more federal red tape
than any administration in history
we fought for free and fair trade
unleashed
american energy and in three short years
businesses created more than seven
million
good paying jobs including twelve
thousand jobs
right here in the hawkeye state
[Music]
you know it's amazing you think about
jobs in the city and on the farm
when joe biden was vice president
america actually lost two hundred
thousand manufacturing
jobs and the last president was asked
about it
remember it was the summer of 2016.
president obama was asked if those jobs
were ever coming back and he just said
what magic wand do you have
that's right we didn't need a magic wand
we just needed president donald trump in
the white house
500 000 manufacturing jobs created
in just three years including 11 000
right here in the state of iowa
and when it comes and when it comes to
agriculture
so important in this state you know
iowa reminds me so much of the state of
indiana where i'm from
this state is many things but in its
heart of hearts it's agriculture
and when joe biden was vice president we
saw
taxes being raised on american family
farmers we saw
regulations that were compromising and
eroding the private property rights of
farmers
we saw them walking away from america's
great commitment
to ethanol and a renewable fuel
standards
but under president donald trump we cut
taxes for family farmers we allowed
immediate expensing of equipment on our
farms
we got rid of the waters of the usa
rule restored private property rights
for farmers
stood with ethanol producers
and we repealed the death tax for nearly
every family farm
in america
and on ethanol you all remember
president trump came to council bluffs
and announced that e-15 is now available
year-round
that's what we call promises made and
promises cap
we fought every day to deliver for
iowa's farmers
that's why i was really pleased today
flying out here on air force two
when i heard that president trump and i
today are actually becoming the first
sitting president
and vice president in history to be
named
honorary members of the corn growers
association
[Music]
thank you for that and i promise you
we're going to stand
with corn growers we're going to stand
for ethanol for four more years
and you know all the progress that we've
made for corn growers and for
agriculture it couldn't have been
possible
without the strong support of both of
your senators
the shy and retiring senator chuck
grassley
you give chuck grassley a round of
applause i'm telling you what he is a
champion
for iowa and iowa's farmers
and it wouldn't have been possible
without senator joni ernst in the united
states senate
and when it comes to trade so important
to agriculture you know
iowa like where i'm from you do two
things well you make things and
you grow things and then you sell them
to the world when we took office
literally half of our trade deficit was
with one
country communist china
now joe biden had been a cheerleader for
communist china all along the way
he literally said that the rise of china
was a positive development
and he scoffed at the idea that china
was even a competitor
of the united states but under president
donald trump
we put china on notice we said the era
of economic surrender
is over we imposed tariffs
on china's goods and when china
retaliated
against american farmers president trump
was there 28 billion dollars
in direct support for agriculture
and we're going to keep standing strong
until china
opens their markets to what we grow
and what we make
and closer to home when it comes to our
trading partners to the north and to the
south
we all remember nafta right
i mean the truth is that 25 years after
nafta was passed we saw about
60 000 factories that were closed
jobs moved south of the border and
democrats for years loved to complain
about nafta didn't they joni
but when joe biden was vice president
and long before
they never lifted a finger to do
anything about it
even as we saw jobs moving overseas
but the man who wrote the art of the
deal
got a way better deal for america
nafta is gone and the usmca
is here to stay and it's a win for iowa
workers
and a win for iowa farmers
you know experts tell us that we're
actually going to sell 2.2 billion more
in agricultural exports to canada and
mexico under the usmca
with nearly half of iowa's exports go
into those two countries
usmca is a win for iowa
[Music]
when it comes to jobs in the city and on
the farm president trump has been
delivering
for the people of iowa and we're going
to keep right on deliverance for four
more years
the men and women of iowa we have a
choice to make
when it comes to this economy and i need
you to talk to your neighbors and
friends about it
over what remains between now and
election day
i think it's a choice between a trump
booming economy
and a biden depression you know a recent
nonpartisan study came out and said that
under joe biden's
economic policies america would lose 5
million
jobs and the average household income
would
decline by 6 500 a year
so as you're after you leave here today
and warm up i want you to find a family
member a neighbor or friend that hasn't
decided what they're doing yet on
november 3rd
and i want you to tell him you were out
at the airport you ran into mike and he
just said
he just had one question he wanted it
it's just easy
just one question we see that gdp number
this morning we see america coming back
getting back on our feet after this
great challenging year through which
were passed
and i just want you to look at them and
say no really seriously
who do you really think can bring the
american economy all the way back
ask him who do you really think can
bring this economy back bigger and
better than ever before
a career politician who spent 47 years
in washington
raising taxes growing government waving
a white flag of economic surrender
on trade or a proven job
creator who's overseeing the fastest
economic recovery in history
so for our families for our future for a
great
american comeback
we need four more years of president
donald trump in the white house
you tell them i said it
so it's about jobs it's about our
security
it's about our prosperity but it's also
about the rule of law
which is the foundation of our
prosperity
and i couldn't be more proud to report
to each and every one of you as i stand
here today
president trump has appointed more than
220
conservative men and women to our
federal courts
at every level
including justice neil gorsuch justice
brett kavanaugh
and justice amy coney barrett
i'm telling you something i'll tell you
what she did
she just an incredible job
we couldn't be more proud of her back in
indiana
which is where she's from but now
she belongs to america and she is going
to be justice barrett is going to be an
incredible
justice on the supreme court of the
united states
i truly believe it and the progress we
made think about that
transforming our judiciary
none of that would have been possible i
got to say it again
without the strong and principled
support of both of your senators
from the great state of iowa but it is
one more reason why we need a principled
conservative representing iowa
on the senate judiciary committee we
need
six more years of senator joni ernst
in the senate
[Music]
i'm just telling you i'm telling you
each and every day
the difference that it makes to have
allies and to have a republican majority
in the united states senate
and you know this is really about this
is about our liberties
we talk about prosperity and we talk
about security and those are paramount
in our minds
but protecting and ensuring
our god-given liberties in this country
is at the very center of who we are
and i want to assure you of a president
who's appointed men and women who will
uphold
those god-given liberties like the
freedom of speech
the freedom of religion and the second
amendment right to keep and bear
arms and we're going to keep appointing
strong and principled conservatives
for four more years as the truth is um
when you look back at the days when joe
biden was vice president
our liberties were under assault in our
most cherished values
i mean when joe biden was vice president
we saw the conscience rights of doctors
and nurses
and religious charities eroded i mean
they actually
hauled into court a group of catholic
nuns
to force them to compromise their faith
to live under the standards of obamacare
president donald trump we've stood
strong for the religious freedom of
every american of
every faith we restored the conscience
rights of doctors nurses and religious
charities and president donald trump
ended the assault on the little sisters
of the poor
and the supreme court of the united
states made it permanent
[Music]
and i just promise you we're going to
continue to stand strong for what we
cherish most
because it matters because it's been
the freedom of religion itself has been
under ridicule
you know i mentioned judge barrett and
senator ernst will remember this
but two years ago when judge amy coney
barrett was being
being considered for the court of
appeals before the senate
she came under attack because of her
devout
in faith hollywood liberals began
mocking her faith
and the democrat leader on
the judiciary committee actually said
her faith was a concern because she said
the dogma lives loudly within you
and hollywood liberals were attacking
her faith ever since
well i got a message for the democrats
in washington
and for their friends in hollywood that
dogma lives loudly
in me that dogma lives loudly in you
and the right to live and work and
worship according to the dictates of our
faith lives loudly in the constitution
of the united states of america
[Applause]
it's not just been about our liberties
it's been about life you all in iowa
deserve to know that joe biden and
kamala harris support taxpayer funding
of abortion
all the way up to the moment of birth
and they're calling for record increases
in funding for abortion
at home and abroad
but for me i couldn't be more proud to
serve as vice
president to a president who stands
without apology for the sanctity of
human life
i mean in our first week in office
president trump restored the mexico city
policy that prevented taxpayer dollars
from being used
to promote abortion around the world
and i got to cast the tie-breaking vote
in the united states senate
that allowed states like iowa to defund
planned parenthood
president donald trump is the most
pro-life president in american history
and we're going to stand for life for
four more years
so we made great progress in our first
three years we rebuilt our military we
revived our economy
we stood for liberties and life and the
rule of law
and none of that would have been
possible without the strong and
consistent support of iowa's republican
delegation to congress
so right after you reelect president
donald trump
and right after you send senator joni
ernst back to the senate
we need you to send david young
and ashley henson to a new republican
majority
in washington d.c and retire nancy
pelosi
once and for all
out i'm telling you
david young ashley henson nancy pelosi
out
that's the equation right so let's get
it done
ashley thank you so much run a great
campaign it's incredible
you know when you look at what we were
able to accomplish in those
first three years with the support of
the people of iowa
i think there's only one way you can
describe it in three short years
we made america great again am i right
and then the coronavirus struck from
china
but before the first documented case
anywhere in america
president trump did what no president
ever done before he suspended all travel
from china
the second largest economy in the world
president trump put the health of
america first
now you all deserve to know joe biden
called that xenophobic
he said it was hysterical he actually
wrote a couple days earlier that banning
any travel during a global pandemic
would quote make things worse
but joe biden got it wrong president
trump got it right
and i can tell you as the head of the
white house coronavirus task force
president trump's decision to suspend
all travel from china
saved untold american lives because it
bought us
invaluable time to stand up the greatest
national mobilization since
world war ii
we reinvented testing we saw to the
manufacturing distribution
of billions of supplies of ppe we
developed medicines
known as therapeutics that are saving
lives and we are on track
to have the first coronavirus vaccine
before the end of this year with
millions of doses
for the american people
[Music]
it's extraordinary and even as we're
seeing cases
rising in parts of the country people of
iowa can be confident that we're going
to continue
we're going to continue to work around
the clock to assure that all of our
doctors and nurses
have all the support they need to give
any iowa family impacted by the
coronavirus the level of care we'd want
for a member of our family now we'll get
through this
and we'll get through this together but
i have to pause for a second and give
some credit where credit is due
because all along the way the people of
iowa have witnessed
the steady strong
and compassionate leadership of governor
kim
[Applause]
reynolds
i've worked with governors in all 50
states and our territories and i must
tell you that governor reynolds
innovation on testing
early on the distribution of ppe to
doctors and nurses even up to this very
hour and moment
i'll tell you president and i are
grateful
and the people of iowa are blessed to
have governor kim
reynolds in the governor's office at
such a time as this
let's hear it again for your great
governor and the job that she's done
incredible leader so working with
governor reynolds i promise you
we're going to continue to meet this
moment
we're going to continue to protect the
vulnerable save lives
and develop life-saving medicines
until the day comes when you put this
coronavirus in the past
and under president donald trump we're
opening up america again
[Applause]
it's amazing to think with the
leadership of your president and the
leadership of your governor
in just the last five months we've
already seen eleven and a half million
americans go back to work
including nearly a hundred thousand
people
all across the hawkeye state
we're opening up america again you saw
in those numbers this morning the
american economy is roaring back
but you all deserve to know joe biden is
talking about shutting down our economy
and the headlines today tell us actually
that several european countries are
already starting to shut down
so you can bet that joe biden will lock
down the american economy if he ever
makes it to the white house
but we're not going to let it happen
we're going to meet this moment with
american
compassion and ingenuity
we're going to distribute the vaccine
and defeat
the virus and bring america back bigger
and better than ever before
men and women i appreciate you coming
out today but i
i think you all know the choice in this
election has never been clearer
the stakes have never been higher
i mean iowa knows more than most states
about presidential politics
the state always plays an outsized role
in setting the course of the nation and
i i just wanted to come here today to
make sure you understand
not just what we've done and the choice
that we face but the
the issues that will face future
generations of americans based on
what we decide five days from now
you know when you look at their agenda
higher taxes
open borders socialized medicine a green
new deal
it's clear
joe biden would be nothing more than a
trojan horse for the radical low
now joe biden has said that democracy is
on the ballot
well i think our economic recovery is on
the ballot
i think law and order are on the ballot
but there are also things far more
foundational to our country that are on
the bound
in this election i think it's not going
to be so much whether america ends up
more republican or more democrat
more liberal or more conservative more
red or more blue
i think the choice in this election is
whether america remains america
[Music]
it's whether we're gonna we're gonna
chart a course
for the future for our children and our
grandchildren
build on our great heritage of faith
and family and freedom
and patriotism
or whether we're going to let joe biden
and the radical left
surrender our nation to policies that
would shut down our economy
topple our heritage of freedom abandon
traditional values and set us on an
inevitable path
of socialism and american decline
so for everything that has always made
this country
exceptional and great
for our very freedom and way of life
men and women of iowa we need to decide
right here
and right now that joe biden will never
be president of the united states we're
going to re-elect
president donald trump for four more
years
[Music]
you know when the president called me to
join this ticket four years ago i really
didn't know him that well
and some people think we're a little bit
different
but i got to tell you we've gotten to be
very close friends i've served at his
side every day these last four years
and i want to tell you folks i've been
there when the cameras are off
and the klig lights are off i've watched
him endure
unrelenting resistance and opposition
like i've never seen before from the
democratic party
i've watched this president endure
unrelenting
and unfair attacks by their allies in
the national media
but there's not a day gone by
that i haven't personally seen president
donald trump
get up turn his face like flint against
the wind
and fight to keep the promises that he
made
to the people of this country now it's
our turn to fight for him
it's on iowa i need you to bring it
i need you to bring it the stakes are
that high
and it's all down to you it really is
so a couple things i want to ask you to
do and then i'm going to let you all get
in out of the cold
but give yourselves a i love these
gloved applauses
give yourself a gloved applause will you
for coming out today i'm just so proud
proud to be with you today what a great
state
thank you all so i got it you got to do
a couple of things
i checked on my way here early voting's
already started
so maybe before the day is out
i need you to vote iowa vote to reelect
president donald trump
for four more years
the president cast his vote this weekend
karen and i cast our votes in
indianapolis
so i need you to go get it done
i mean if you've already requested an
absentee ballot you can
vote absentee in person right
and i checked on the way here if you
don't know where to go with it
you can head down to the polk county
election office
122nd avenue
suite a
open today friday saturday and monday
8-5
[Applause]
and remember friends don't let friends
vote alone
bring a family member bring a neighbor
bring a co-worker and vote
to re-elect president donald trump for
four more years
so number one
i love you too
so after you vote with a friend
number two i got something else i want
to ask you to do
i want you to tell somebody why you came
and stood out in the cold here today
i mean i want you to i want you to tell
them that
what the stakes are in this election i
mean i think this
is this is not the most important
election in my lifetime i think this
might be the most important election in
the life of this nation
for all the reasons that i said because
the choice is that dramatic
and as america is standing back up
through the most challenging year in my
lifetime
it's never been more important that we
continue to build on the foundation
of american greatness and so go tell
your neighbors and friends you know i'll
always believe
that what happened here in iowa and
across america in 2016 was that
you know in a very real sense people
weren't
listening to the pollsters and the
pundits they were just talking to each
other
it's like i said at the very start
people were people were listening to the
vision
and sensing the leadership qualities
of our president and you were talking to
your family members and your friends and
saying
i think that sounds about right i mean
you believed
that america could be strong again could
be prosperous again
and so i want you to talk to your
neighbors and friends and
encourage them one more time because i
can tell you
joe biden is talking about dark days
coming up
but under president donald trump the
best is yet to come
and finally after you be sure to vote
tell your neighbors and friends every
day the next five days
i'd encourage you to do one more thing
you know i've traveled around this
country the last four years and i'm
convinced
of two things
that america is a freedom-loving nation
america is a nation of faith
[Applause]
and so if you're inclined to bow the
head and bend the knee from time to time
encourage you to do that over the next
five days
and when you pray pray with confidence
in these challenging times
that if his people who are called by his
name will humble themselves and pray and
turn
that he'll do like he's always done in
the long and storied history
of this great nation he'll hear from
heaven
and he'll heal this land
[Applause]
this one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice
for all so pray for america
pray for all of the american people
it'll make a difference i promise you so
thank you for coming out today
give your great governor another round
of applause will you she not only comes
the great leader governor reynolds give
ashley hinton another round of applause
she's going to be a great member of
congress
and give a special round of applause to
the
senator joni ernst has been such a
champion and we're going to get her back
for six more years
and i'm just absolutely convinced seeing
this hearty bunch
here in the hawkeye state
you i'm telling you what you all you all
look great today thank you so much for
being here
but if all of us do all that we need to
do between now and november 3rd
we're going to have a great victory all
across iowa and all across america with
joni ernst
in a renewed republican majority in the
senate
with ashley henson and david young in a
new republican majority in the house of
representatives
with president donald trump back in the
white house
and with god's help
we will make america great again
again thank you very much iowa
god bless you and god bless america
let's go get it done
[Music]
there's something coming up over new
york city
driver in a trap
[Music]
[Music]
dreams
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
everybody gets to dance
[Music]
a wilderness dollar
[Music]
is
he was a singer back to oklahoma
[Music]
oh
very good
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
everybody gets to dance
you